the 2019 Karen's cup has a really
special place in my heart it was the
first event of its kind here at the st.
Louis chess club with ten of the top
women in the world playing in this
prestigious of that yeah it was such a
great event in so many exciting games
like I've shown so many of those games
to my students and so much to learn from
and just so much interesting chess to
follow and it was such a dramatic event
that came down to the very final moments
we had Valentina Goo Nina and Alexander
continue fighting until literally the
last me moves
yeah the two teammates and this is what
commentator stream of right the final
rounds a very competitive event first
place the leader and the follower facing
each other and costanera I believe had
the white pieces so she had a great
opportunity to win the game and just
take the tournament the way and as we
know she didn't manage to do it and
actually Guney and I had the chances to
win and she ended up taking the the
trophy home that's right and $40,000
yeah good faith day
that's right Valentina garena it was
such a memorable tournament for me and
one of my biggest memories was as you
said so many gems for the students
there was a masterpiece that Valentina
played actually on Valentine's Day so
pretty sweet alliteration there where
she sacrifices like all our pieces
starting with this tiny and Bishop takes
86 yeah there was such a great game and
I remember Tonya's such them and I were
doing commentary the kingside and where
there was a kids class at the club when
those kids came to watch us and then we
were going through the game and it was a
beginners group so we're talking about I
got to play in the opening to develop
the pieces and then we go to that game
we're good Nina should I push all her
kingside pawns and her queen is out and
tiny just looked at me I was like I want
to explain this and it was just such a
memorable game and like I've shown this
game to all my students a tactical
sequence and how to find the checkmate
and I think it's definitely something
we're gonna be seeing in technician
chess books absolutely and I really like
about that game that you can show it to
a very strong player and of course
they'll be really impressed like I wish
I play at that game
or you could show it to somebody who
just started to learn about track mates
because there's that final move rook f8
check which leads to a beautiful chat
main and it kind of goes to show how
turn
like the Karen's cup has such wide
appeal they appeal to the top players in
the world but they also appeal to the
little girl who just learned to play
chess yeah I mean any game that has a
tactical sequence I think it's very
appealing to everyone it doesn't I don't
think it matters what level you're at I
think seeing or playing solving a nice
tactical sequence is such a good feeling
like if you play a beautiful tactic in
your game it just just feel so good
about it
even if you have a bad tournament if she
had a bad tournament and I think she
ended her tournament on that with that
game she would feel so good about it I
know I would that's one of the cool
things about chess there are two ways to
win you could win by winning the
tournament or you could win by playing
an amazing game that you can replay
forever one person that also came very
close to winning the tournament to the
surprise a lot of people because she was
a big underdog was seven-time US Women's
Champion Irina crash yeah she was having
a very good tournament in the beginning
and yeah definitely she was an underdog
because I think at that point she had
dropped some of her ratings so I think
she was one of the lower rated players
but I think she's also feels very
comfortable playing in st. Louis I know
I do because I played here so many times
I think it was home turf for her and she
had a very good tournament where I saw
the performance who finished third which
I believe she over performed
significantly that was a great result
for her as well yeah and I think the
impact of this tournament was also so
huge I mean we have had the Sinquefield
cup or so many years but here's the
Karen's Cup which is named after dr.
Jeanne Singh Fjell - co-founded the st.
Louis Chess Club eleven twelve years ago
now with rec Singh field and so it was
named after Jeanne and I really think
that what excited the chest community
about this is it was kind of obvious
immediately that this was gonna be a
fixture on the calendar this was not a
one-and-done event and in fact we're
sitting here now with a 20/20 event and
what an incredible field we have yeah
and I think this is something that the
top female players look forward to
because when I just played in Gibraltar
and I said that a few of the players who
are playing here we're missing there and
I believe the reason they didn't play
there because they were too close and
they chose to prepare for the Karen's
Cup and this year it's significantly
stronger because we have the reigning
woman's world champion she just defended
her title successfully we have Hampi
Quintero who took two years off
playing chess and she's coming back and
she just won one of the Grand Prix
events and she also is the current
women's rapid champion Katerina laughs
no also didn't play last year the
current women's blitz champion she's
playing here and I think it's going to
be much stronger event and a lot closer
absolutely I mean it's just an
incredible event we have nine
grandmasters and the talented 16 year
old charissa hip and eye I have a
feeling that it's gonna be one of those
events like the Sinquefield Cup we're
just two or three years of chess and it
feels like it's been around forever
because it's so rich there's so much
that happens in each event I'm also
really excited that we have Maria Musa
chook we didn't have any Musa chick
sister last year so that's a good
addition to the field as well yeah she's
definitely a strong player and she's
also she has won the Women's World Cup
which is such a difficult tournament to
win in such a difficult tournament to
play so she's unfortunately we didn't
get both of them but it's very good to
have her and we'll see how she does here
and of course an increased prize fund as
well and a trophy designed by Tiffany's
so now when they say that every woman
wants a Tiffany's blue box will know
that they mean a chest trophy and not
hurrying or maybe both fat so who would
you be your pick to win this year my
pick to win this year I'm gonna go out
and say Humpty canario huge fan of humpy
and her games she has just like such a
fluid style oh that's a good choice yeah
I think she has come back so she
probably has a lot of hunger for chest
she's probably been training really hard
after taking so many years off chess and
she's definitely good peek but I think I
would go with you in June I think a
world champion is always a favorite to
win a tournament and I am Not sure I was
looking at her games in the World
Championship I felt like something was a
little off but I think by now she would
she's already recovered unless she's
really tired I think she's definitely
the favorite to win this was you in June
it's just such a pleasure to have the
world champion at our tournament it's so
much like when we have a sink filled Cup
and we have magnets the difference
between that and like the one year that
he didn't play because of a conflict
with the World Championship preparation
it's just it adds this energy into the
event you know and the public name tree
increases so of course that's just
thrilling and I know that everybody is
is gonna be really excited about this
event and it's gonna be a tough fight I
mean we know that the female chess
players in general tend to play very
very long and fighting games like if you
look at some of the world championship
games or last year's Karen's Cup games
you and I as commentators they're gonna
have some long nights ahead and I can't
wait yeah but it's very exciting when
the games are interesting and there is a
lot to them and you know you can talk a
lot about them and it's just
commentating it's just a fun thing to do
I think that this year is gonna be great
and one thing's for sure that the
Karen's Cup is going to be a fixture for
a long time to come and a dream of many
kids and girls who see another great
tournament with some of the top women in
the world yeah that's definitely already
the top woman of the world are looking
up to it and I'm sure there's a whole
new generation who is looking forward to
playing in this event